hi this is presh hulwaker and welcome to
the mind your decisions channel today i
want to discuss sports betting and a
guaranteed way that you can win on any
sport that does not end in a tie
a small disclaimer is that i don't
encourage gambling of any kind or sports
betting this video is only meant to
illustrate some cool math
but it will be a cool technique you can
use this to have a guaranteed win on
the nfl super bowl
the nba finals
the wimbledon championships or any
tennis grand slam
you can use it for the world series of
cricket
you could even use it for olympic
curling like i said you can really use
this method to get a guaranteed win on
any number of sports as long as they
don't end in a tie
the only prerequisite is that you're
going to need two friends
who are willing to accept reasonable
gambles
that is gambles they think that are
actually in their favor
so how is this going to work
we'll set up an example where there are
two teams a and b that are going to play
and you have two friends who are fans of
different teams
so
one of your friends a is a fan of team a
and he just thinks they're going to
crush uh team b he thinks there's a
three and four chance that
that his team is going to win
now friend b really thinks that his team
uh is is much superior and he thinks
there's a three-fifth chance
that his team will win
so you have two friends who both think
that their team is going to win
this happens all the time
is uh so
what what can you do this is a normal
situation and you can take advantage of
this to make a very favorable situation
for yourself
so what you need to do
is you need to set up bets with each of
the friends
as follows
with friend a you're going to pay them
four dollars if their team wins
and they pay you five dollars if their
team loses
uh with friend b you set up a very
similar bet
uh
you pay them if they're four dollars if
their team wins
uh and they're gonna pay you five
dollars if their team loses
so you have a situation where you're
gonna pay each friend if their team wins
they're gonna pay you a little more if
their team loses
uh but we we can't just say that both of
these friends are going to accept these
bets just because you offer them
uh we're going to go through the math to
show that each friend actually thinks
this is a good bet for them
so we'll start out with friend a uh who
thinks his team has a three-fourths
chance to win
so the friend's going to think about the
bet in terms of the expected value
this is
mathematically
the uh
you know they're either going to be the
events that team a wins and team a loses
and
uh the person's going to have to pay out
certain amounts in each situation
so the expected value is
the amount the friend has to
wins if team a wins which is four
dollars times
this friend thinks this will have a
three or four chance of happening
uh we will add to that they will have to
pay out five dollars
in uh the one and four situation where
their team loses
so when we run through the numbers
this bet you know friend a views this
bet as having a positive
1.75 expected value
this is a tremendously high expected
value it means they're winning a dollar
75 on average
you know all vegas bets uh uh you know
all other most gambles in life
uh maybe there will be a little positive
expected value uh in actual casinos most
of the bets are negative
so this is actually a hugely positive
expected value
and
for that reason you would expect that
friend a is going to want to accept this
gamble
we will do a very similar calculation
for friend b
uh the only difference here is that that
friend b has has a different belief they
think that their team b has a
three-fifth chance to win
regardless when we run through this
expected value
friend b is going to see
expect a positive 40 cents on the bet
again this is a positive expected value
it's not as good a bet for friend b as
it is for friend a
that really doesn't matter
if you see a bet which has a positive
expected value that still means it's in
your favor
and uh
we would expect that friend b is also
going to want to accept this gamble
so now both friend a and b are willing
participants you're not trying to con
them in any way they both think that
you've offered them
a good bet
but what you've done is actually created
a situation where you can always win you
uh
and we'll we'll go through the diagram
of why this is
um the top branch is what happens when
team a wins
in that case you're gonna pay uh four
dollars to friend a
but then friend b pays you five dollars
so on net that means you net a positive
one dollar if team a wins
in another circumstance if team b wins
you are going to win five dollars from
friend a and then you're gonna have to
pay out four dollars to friend b
but still this means you're gonna
have one dollar left over for yourself
so either way no matter what happens you
are guaranteed to win one dollar and
you've offered your friends bets they're
willing to take
so you've created a situation of perfect
bets
where you are always going to win and
that is the guaranteed way
of winning on sports betting
so
you can think about how to use this in
practice uh it will you know your
friends are gonna have different beliefs
about the games you'll have to set up
the bets differently
uh if your two friends find out about
this they may not necessarily be happy
that you keep winning
so
whether you can actually do this over
and over again
like i said i don't recommend gambling
or sports betting of any kind
but this is a useful concept
and i will mention this is somewhat how
sports betting
works in vegas and other uh gambling
houses they do set up situations where
uh not necessarily for one game they're
always going to win but over time they
hope that you know over several
different games
they create an edge for themselves in
the house
and it's obviously much more complicated
but that is somewhat the principle of
how
sports betting works
i hope you enjoyed this video please
subscribe to the channel
you can also follow the mind your
decisions blog i post weekly puzzles on
monday weekly game theory post on
tuesday
and you can also follow me on twitter at
preshtalwalker